hello and welcome to the program a
funeral has been held for a 17-year-old
palestinian who was shot and killed by
israeli forces in the occupied west bank
[Applause]
palestinian factions have called a
general strike to mourn for ahmed
al-fayyad another teenager was seriously
injured during the raid on a refugee
camp in janine
it happened in the same area where
israeli forces killed al jazeera
journalist abu aklay last week
let's go straight to imran khan
who was outside damascus gate and
occupied east jerusalem imran what more
can you tell us about the strike firstly
well the raid happened in the early
hours of a saturday morning and that's
where amjad the 17 year old was killed
by israeli forces and another was
critically wounded the operation uh
lasted about an hour that we're hearing
but still the israelis are mounting
these nighttime raids on a much more
regular basis than they have been before
now the funeral has has taken place in
the last couple of hours the mourners
saying that they will get revenge on the
israeli forces for this particular
attack and this killing uh one of the
palestinian factions islamic jihad has
claimed amjad fired as a member
of their ranks and it's likely uh that
they will
intensify their fire what normally
happens is when the israeli forces go
into janine itself and then toward the
refugee camps there's an exchange of
fire the israelis uh firing uh into the
camp itself and indeed janine is where
my colleague shireen abwakley was killed
last week
stay with me imran uh because more than
50 u.s politicians want the fbi to
investigate the shooting of shireen
among them is the republic republican
congressman andre carson he's tweeted
the following the killing of al jazeera
reporter and fellow american shireen abu
aklay was not only a tragedy it was an
affront to press freedom and to all
americans it went on to add we need
answers and accountability from the
israeli government
well as imran just said janine is where
al jazeera journalist sharina wakley was
shot and killed just a week ago and the
channel continues to demand a rapid
independent and transparent
investigation
she was shot in the head by israeli
forces while she was on assignment
on the day of her funeral israeli forces
stormed the procession beat mourners
causing pallbearers to almost drop her
coffin and that didn't deter thousands
of palestinians from marching through
occupied east jerusalem to take part in
her funeral and burial members of the
international community have condemned
her killing and continued to call for
investigation
abraclay was with al jazeera for 25
years covering the story of the israeli
occupation she was known as the voice of
palestine
the calls continue for there to be
accountability for shireen's death how
is israel responding to these
international pressures
quite frankly it isn't israel hasn't
said that they will open a new
investigation in fact they're sticking
to their guns they're saying uh that
they won't uh have an investigation by
the israeli military police now the
reason for that is quite simple they
would have to open a criminal
investigation into a serving soldier who
was on an active military operation
politically that's completely untenable
it's something the opposition would use
to bash the government with it's
something that'd be very unpopular
amongst the israeli public it's
something that simply they will not do
but this international pressure is
building the americans like you say 57
lawmakers have signed a petition uh to
try and get the fbi to come and
investigate however that's caused some
confusion here as well because uh there
is the idea that there should be an
automatic uh
investigation that's triggered by a
death such as this the fbi should be on
the ground already say many palestinians
however the palestinian reaction is very
interesting they have always maintained
that they knew that they the israelis
would not mount an investigation they're
not disappointed by this but they are
increasing their calls for an
independent
international investigation to take
place
okay thank you for that imran khan bear
from outside damascus gate in occupied
east jerusalem
well amnesty international secretary
general has condemned israel's decision
not to investigate the murder in a tweet
agnes kalamad said the following it's an
additional violation of sharim's right
to life and a clear violation of
israel's obligation under international
law
one amongst many she goes on to say this
is what repression and domination look
like some lives simply don't matter